hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast on risks of bias in in vivo
research and what to do about them
my name is Emily Sara from the
University of Edinburgh and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the side window by
clicking on the screen icon in a narrow
right-hand corner of a side window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing the presentation please click
the support button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem through through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker professor
Malcolm McLeod I've been with the
professor of neurology and translation
and neuroscience
whom I've had the joy of working with
for the last 11 years
mothman's research interests about
revolve around developing tools to
provide unbiased summary of what is
wedding rain including tools to assess
whether it affects an animal which may
be overstated and then using this
information to help guide better design
a pinnacle child testing in humans 13
treatment to delivery I'll now turn it
over to Malcolm okay is pretty waiting
yeah well thank you very much Emily and
thank you everyone for dialing in what
for some people will be quite early in
the day and for others will be quite
late in the day
so over the next 50 minutes or so I want
to give you up whistles talk to her
about what I think are the important
risks of buyers an analyst
I won't be as with certain practitioners
might do about it
I start off with some disclosures I'm a
member of the UK home office animals and
science committee responsible for
setting at least some of the regulatory
framework for animal research in the UK
I'm a member of the UK Commission for
human medicines which is responsible for
giving regulatory recommendations for
approval for new medicines but most
importantly for you I have sought in the
past and will continue to seek funding
for work
in this area so you will understand if I
try and tell you at everything that I do
it's fantastic and things but them very
very interesting and of course people
should give me lots of research funding
to do more to do more orbit and so I'm a
translational neuroscientist here's an
example of a translational problem and
we have a quite a few of this the
science both in Wales where this is
from' and in Scotland where road signs
are given in the English language and
then underneath there's a translation of
what it means in the local language
whatever that might be and this science
is no entry for heavy-duty vehicles
residential sight only but in fact the
wealth translation says I am NOT in the
office at the moment send any work to be
translated so this translational Road
scientists if you like has misunderstood
the black box into which they have sent
their data their English text string and
accepted without any further thought
what's come out of their black box
machine in this case one assumes an
automated email response and some of the
problems that we have been to assert
come about for these reasons here is
another example and this is work using a
technique called functional MRI scanning
the premise of this is that when part of
the brain is active it requires more
blood that is achieved through a very
dilute iterative process increase in the
local blood flow and that change in
oxygen level in the blood can be
detected in a functional MRI scanner
through something called the blood
oxygen level dependent signal
signature
signal and now these machines are very
temperamental they often require to be
set up very precisely to have their
knobs twiddled and their egos tended so
they give the right pictures and this
group in Boston used to set up and trim
the machine every Monday morning and
there's a competition to see who could
bring in the most egregious piece of
organic material for the setup on the
scanner on one morning it was Craig's
turn and on his way to work he
remembered that he'd forgotten to bring
in something organic for the scanner and
but fortunately his roots to work to
ambass the Boston fish market and he
realized that no one had had a salmon in
the scanner before so he got a salmon
hardly took it into when he took it into
work and they set up a scan and they
twiddle the notes until the scanner was
working properly and then their human
volunteer for that morning didn't show
and the genius that he had was to put
the salmon through here in our eye scan
so one mature Atlantic salmon waiting
about 3.8 pounds and measuring 18 inches
long participated in the test and the
salmon was a was asked to perform a task
the task involved picturing our series
of photographs depicting human
individuals in social situations rhythms
are specified emotional valence or the
human was happy or sad or perplexed or
confused and the salmon was out to
determine in which emotion the human in
the picture must have been experiencing
several active voxels were found in the
Salmons brain cavity close to its
equivalent of the human orbital frontal
cortex which lights up and most of these
scanners I have very high significance
threshold and as they say either they
stumbled onto a rather amazing discovery
in terms of postmortem
a theological cognition and that's to
say that they're dead salmon could think
or there must be something wrong with
this methodology with this approach and
gave them what must be a false positive
result for which they are were awarded
the ignoble prize in neuroscience in
2012 and rightly so
and positive or misses work from Lewis
Dayton who's ahead
and you're a scientist unfortunately not
not in my group they see did something
very smart she was interested in looking
at cell death in a cell line called the
SX sy fine Y cell line so she exposed
these cells to star a sporran and then
looked at changes in a messenger RNA
expression between the ground on
stimulated state in the dying cells to
see which genes were turned on in this
process or of active cell death or
apoptosis and induced by star aspirin
and she got 13 genes that were regulated
as she said in a way to a website called
ingenuity pathway analysis that comes
back and tells you if the genes are
regulated together and a pathway and if
they are of what that pathway is and
what it does is give you an IPS core and
the IPS core is the negative logarithm
of the odds of those teams being
associated together by chance alone so
an IP a school of 10 would mean that the
p-value was 10 to minus 2 and so so she
got the results back but it didn't make
any sense to her the machine seemed to
be telling her that these genes were
regulated in a way which she thought was
implausible I'm rather than believed the
Machine are well fraud sinus problem she
thought she's test the Machine so she
went the gene base and selected 13 genes
at random and send them to IPA and then
she did it again and again and again and
she didn't have thousand times with a
thousand sets of 15 randomly selected
genes and got back the IPS core and
here's the distribution of the IPS core
in this graph on the right and you can
see that the IDS scores read from 4 to
38 so it didn't call any of these random
collections of genes at less than 1 in
10,000 and the median score was 1 in 1
million million million so what this
tells you is that genes are regulated
together by chance alone because they
happen to be in the same cells serving
the functions of that cell but these
kind of web-based analysis tools often
don't tell you very much more than the
bleeding obvious
and here's an example much closer to
home for me and this is testing a drug
in an animal ischemia model this is a
model of ischemic stroke in the rat
really rat is exposed to either control
conditions and you can see an impact
volume of about two hundred cubic
millimeters or half-doors load on foods
made and then through those low dose
three tomato you can see a reduction in
infarct size and association with this
probe treatment I know showing you the
statistical significance testing but is
statistically significant but the
problem is when I tell you that happens
lordose glutamate his tenth the minus
120 more and truly luminous blue
tomatoes 10 to minus sixty more then
noise of Europe Earth from earlier with
a began to lose constant will know that
there isn't any glutamate in either of
those columns and so this must be
something wrong well either homeopathy
works and I don't think it does or
there's something wrong with it widely
used experimental technique or the way
is analyzed so we were interested in
translating treatments from the Morison
models into clinical trials in humans
and over ten years ago identified 1100
1026 blogs which had been tested in some
form of and people and people through
model over 600 tested in animal models
of focal cell anemia of which 374
remarkably improved outcome in those
animal models someone would imagine for
a translational stroke neuroscientists
like myself and the gradient of work for
us to do and in fact some of those drugs
had been tested in clinical trial and
ninety seven of them and and off doors
one and one worked in human stroke that
was clot-busting treatment with TPA
interestingly and worked and was tested
in human stroke not because of the
animal data although there is animal
data and Emily introduced me and
systematically reviewed those animal
data but it was tested in humans through
because it was affected and I called me
a human condition myocardial ischemia
Marquardt limb function and in fact
there are three treatments which are in
routine clinical use aspirin stroking
and care and decompress of hand-cranked
me all tested in human clinical file
without ever being near an animal so
there's a real question as to the extent
to which the board to the research
animal research and straw has
contributed so far to the development of
effective treatments and what I'm
interested in is why that might be and I
think the preclinical trials field to
translate if animal studies mislead and
animal studies will mislead if the
conclusions are confounded by bias
because how the experiment was done how
the data were analyzed it incomplete
data are available to the people making
the judgments about proceeding if the
studies used the wrong sample size or at
least a little mortal and I'll try and
cover some of those issues as we go
through so here's the story of a drug
called any twine or 5:19 developed by
AstraZeneca to treat football service
you know to treat stroke and test
marketed under treatment instead of IED
so certainly were that they would make
one set of them survive following a
straw and they arranged in total three
clinical trials involving five and a
half thousand patients and in the 48
hours following publication of the last
again neutral clinical trial
their share price fell by 17 percent a
market valuation of nine point six
billion dollars under took them six
years to get that market valuation back
so a disaster for them and when we
looked after the event and a pool talk
systematic review of the animal data
which had supported the clinical trial
program we found high headline efficacy
with a forty four percent improvement in
outcome but not very much animal data
fewer than 600 animals in total and
efficacy much reduced in high quality
studies show you there and much reduced
in animals the hypertension and I'll
show you that also somewhat true block
do we use well we use systematic review
and meta-analysis the number of
excellent review articles about these
systematic reviews review where the
criteria for identifying and considering
information and data are determined in
advance and are transparent and this
contrasts with and is much less biased
and narrative review and meta-analysis
is a statistical technique to combine
data from separate experiment and you
can use it and clinicians often use it
to give her an overall best estimate of
a treatment of it but we use it more to
understand the impact of other things
what that treatment effect is no it
might be related to the treatment itself
that goes that timing it might be
related to the animal the age of the
animal its sex whether there's any
comorbidities and importantly and
crucially it might be related to the
design of the experiments and this and a
number of other issues in research are
set out in a series of articles in The
Lancet in 2014 published almost exactly
two years ago which identify find key
stages where research value can be
increased on research which might be
reduced and I'm going to discuss in a
bit of detail as relates to animal
research that studies might take
adequate steps to reduce bias the
studies have published and fool and
lovely reporter studies with
disappointing results but I'm recommend
that series to you as a primer or a
fourth candle role because as you know
what can go wrong usually does and so
the first thing is how the experiment
was done and I'd like to take you back
to the 1960s to Robert Rosenthal and
colleagues who used to teach a course in
comparative psychology and at the end of
the course there are students had to
perform an experiment on the experiment
model for a week and they were
completing competent performance in two
cohorts of animals and one who had been
bred over many generations at berkeley
then our leading center for cognition
research they'd been bred to perform
well and positive tasks such as the
teammates although the team is itself
and the other group were me as dull
they're slightly thicker if you like
country cousins who'd been bred and
inbred over many generations to perform
badly and the tasks administered
theanine and the team is this place in
the stay with them is one of the arms of
the news was always bright and the other
was always dark which was darker with
was bright was flipped according to a
predetermined
learning schedule and the dark arm was
always reinforced with food so rather
like the junior postdoc the rat was
being trained to turn to the dark side
and what they found was firstly that the
maze bright animals performed better
even on the first day of the experiment
when they were naive the cognitive Terry
and while blood cohort O'Bannon was
improved over the five days the
improvement was much more pronounced in
the midbrain animals and the least on
animals furthermore when he asked the
students what they thought of their
animals the Mia's great animals were
inquisitive friendly animals are sort of
ailable you'd like to take home to meet
your mother whereas the nice doll
animals were surly and insolent and in
fact see if the students were bitten by
their Mia's doll animals and in fact the
experiment of the drawers and tile had
done wasn't on the animals it was on the
student but those animals had been
picked at random from the same cages in
the same animal house on the first day
of the experiment and the only
difference between them was in the minds
of the students doing the experiment and
the way those students handled the
animals during the experiment presumably
induced by their pre pre conditions
their preconceptions about what the
animals were like and how they would
perform and perhaps that's fine
they got bitten so he couldn't back -
rio5 nine years risk of bias endure
studies and looking at Empire
four-wheelers and I become four hundred
eight animals again we see this overall
improvement and I come in the dark grey
bath grey bar but when we look at
studies that are randomized with blind
the conduct at least an experiment with
blind assessment of outcome then we see
there are substantially lower efficacy
is significantly lower efficacies in
those animal law risk of bias not one of
those eleven publications meant all
three of those risk of bias items and
the two that had been used by astra to
fuel the clinical trial program make
none so with the benefit of hindsight
the reason that NX lining our pipeline
did not work and humans true is probably
because it doesn't work in animals true
if the animals went ahead big favors
have done to a high enough quality so
when we produce the data some years ago
now we were told the ballot because
stroke and all researchers were amazing
they didn't know what they were doing
they didn't know how to do proper
experiment we needed to look at proper
near a scientist because they would know
what was happening so we looked at some
other neuroscience tania's here's their
lightning again this is from stroke and
then experiments in Alzheimer's disease
and the Morris water maze testing the
efficacy of candidate drugs and
transgenic models of Alzheimer's these
comedians were an abbess trainers
working
cirrhosis and Healy rocks work in
Parkinson's disease showing consistently
that there is significantly lower
estimates of efficacy when investigated
it blinded to treatment group allocation
so that's where we are there and then
there are problems win-win that the
studies were reported to so if for
instance if we look at Hannah's
systematic review of studies of multiple
sclerosis we found almost 10,000
publications and testing about 1,700
interventions we were interested in
about 40 interventions that have been
tested on five or more occasions and
trying to extract the data from those
publications for those drugs and what we
firing that of 202 potential includable
publications we had to include fully 1/3
of them either because they had no bad
outcomes no errors then report the
number of an off the group didn't report
the variants or the number of animals
per group three were completely
uninterpretable
and - in spite of being experiments with
a control group didn't provide any
outcome data for animals in control so
very difficult to understand what they
actually did and to understand what's
happening and looking across our range
of disease model area as to see where
there is problems with neuroscientists
we've narrowed it across Alzheimer's
disease focal ischemia glioma
Huntington's hammer is multiple
sclerosis Marc Cardinal Parton spinal
cord injury over and 2670 one
publications identified in the context
of systematic reviews which we performed
and you can see reporting randomization
overall and fewer than 30% of studies or
the blinded the best assessment of
outcome in about 30% of a power
calculation the y-axis has changed in
about 1% of studies and a complete have
interested in about 10% of studies so
that's a problem and the question is
whether it's really just a problem
largely for the neurosciences you can
see my requirement far from performing
reasonably well here so next we went to
PubMed now every publication in PubMed
has been a unique PubMed ID which is now
our number between one and I think
twenty-six million so if you give me a
random number between 1 and 26 million I
can give you a random publication and we
did that for 2,000 publications and 5
147 about 7% reporting in vivo
experiments where randomization would
have been appropriate what we found was
reporting of randomization and only 17%
of blinding in less than 3% not one
study reporting a power calculation and
about 10% reporting a conflict of
interest statement so it's not just
mirror signs it seems to be poor all
over the piece and when we look at the
change over time you can see there is an
increase in reporting this is in
quintiles of year of publication so the
first quintilis from 1941 to 78 and the
lattice in 2008 to 12 and you could see
there is an increase in the reporting of
randomization is perhaps an increase in
reporting of blinding but there's really
quite a substantial increase in the
reporting of conflicts of interest and
that's important because it implied that
if we can encourage journals to
introduce Paul policies for
randomization and blinding the same way
that it did for conflict of interest
reporting we are there now beyond to
perhaps making some progress you see
there is no change in power calculations
because they're normal so then we were
told that if you take something at
random from pop made of course it's
going to be rubbish and you've got to
know the institution and the group and
the team so you've got to know it comes
from a reliable source unfortunately in
the UK we can identify at least we think
to be a reliable source because we have
this thing called the research
assessment exercise performed in 2008
and again in 2014 so we went to the 2008
research assessment exercise and we are
and we identified five institutions
which had been identified as making an
outstanding contribution to the
internationally excellent position of
the UK in biomedical science and where
the panels have been particularly
impressed by strains within the basic
neurosciences and what we did for those
5 institutions we went to PubMed and
identified all of the publications we
could find for all those institutions
describing experiments using non-human
animal published in the 2 years after
the army
and we find 1173 publications from five
leading institutions this was published
in PLoS Biology until the last ena see
here we find reporting of randomization
of about 15% of blinding of less than
20% of inclusion and exclusion criteria
one of the Landis criteria for
reportedly he should be able to track
every animals reading experiment and
find out what happened to it and power
calculations about 1% and importantly
there are significant differences
between institutions these are
color-coded rather than named to protect
my future employment prospects but you
can see between those institutions
significant differences that we were
able to identify with two people working
for about three months in contrast to
the very many personal models that we
are ae2 to try and make similar
judgments as to the rigor of research so
now we can actually do a comparison
between leading UK institution to the
area where for the years 2009 2010
reporting of randomization was less than
20% if we go to the studies that we
identified predominantly in the
neurosciences and just focus down on
2009 2010 we find about 35% report
randomization so neuroscience is better
than average animal research from
leading UK institutions but when we look
upon it seniors for are fewer
publications but on average publications
in PubMed are selected at random our
long higher rigor significantly higher
rigor than publications from the five
leading UK institutions so I do think
that it's incumbent on institutions and
others to do things about this so
journals I think need to think more
about the alive reporting guidelines and
I know you'll hear more about this in
the context of this conference and the
landis transparency guidelines nature
have really stepped up to the plate with
the change of their publication policy
in May 2013 and we're important with
that essentially an ordered with them to
ascertain what impact that's had and
we're also involved in the randomized
control trial with another publisher to
see where the specific editorial
intervention
funders we need attempts a regular grant
award but as a leader Nagaland police
pointed out in nature a few months ago
now the people who have a major role in
this and who have yet to fulfill that
rule I think largely come from the
institutions who could do much more in
terms of auditing the performance as an
institution of scientists within their
institution I'm providing CPD
opportunities to try and allow people to
improve that performance not in our
punitive aren't you awful and you've
been very bad boys and girls go away and
do better but now we're always included
all of us improving in improving the
quality of the research that we do how
can we help you and us as an institution
to provide to be better quality research
I don't think anyone was ever an
argument with that there's also a
problem with how they need to analyze
let me give an example from Clinical
Research International Study of infarct
survival to Isis to recruiting when I
was in short charges as a junior doctor
which saw that Aspen improves outcome in
my Carmen function but when you do a
post hoc analysis there's a non
significant worst thing about comfor
those born hundred Gemini or a Libra but
what if noise had been patient with
migraine where there was a non
significant outcome neurologists like me
would have spent hours and hours and
hours arguing and cold and songs and
bars about whether we should give
aspirin to MI patients and also it might
mean when in fact the chance
associations let me show you there
these are their Ontario had complained
in a health record system and these near
the automations for hospitalization for
5.3 million residents of Ontario by sign
up birth and you see of course but there
are some some associations here
significantly increased odds of
admission for 24 of the 223 most common
presentation is scorpions having
increased list of lymphoid leukemia
libros having increased rate of
subarachnoid hemorrhage I'm very glad I
am a variable because I think I'm
probably immune to excessive vomiting in
pregnancy but when you try and test this
in a separate validation cord only two
of these 23 come through and then when
you try and correct the multiple testing
none of these 24 conditions
actually phone to be to be significantly
associated so there are real parallels
and testing multiple non pre-specified
hypothesis and in many ways what happens
in the lab can appear to an outsider
looking in as being dated and data
collected followed by hypothesizing
rather than the other way around
and there's also a problem with excess
significance which seems to suggest that
we were only seeing the tip of an
iceberg when we read a paper so this is
looking at over 4,000 experiments which
we've collected in the context of
systematic reviews across a number of
different disease areas and looking at
how many of those we would expect to
find positive findings on the basis of
the underlying effect that was observed
under sort of variation that we were
seeing so this is where the journey
adenosine is group and we would expect
of those 4,000 about 900 to be positive
in fact we see about twice about twice
that highly significant observation and
what this suggests is that overall over
all these diseases but it's not that
this number is artificially high is that
this number here the 4445 is
artificially low and this number should
really be learned about 8,000 to get
this to get 919 positive results and so
our percentage suppression or a
percentage suppression of experimental
findings of about forty seven percent
and are these multiple positive studies
really plausible well if we assume that
a publication describes six experiment
each independent test of an underlying
hypothesis and I assume that underlying
mechanistic hypothesis is correct and
then individual experiments using
different cohorts of animals different
experimental setups I'll each individual
occurs at 50% and that's a that's a
relatively generous assumption for
studies that we look at at Port our
parrot of 30 to 40 percent so the
probability of at least one of those six
experiments being positive is 98 percent
but the probability of all 16 posted
there's only 2 percent which perhaps was
some way to explain and so he doesn't
it's been
or what we find when we meet these
people so if you go to P NES or science
or whatever I read a paper that's got
six independent testable hypotheses
every single test will be statistically
significant so this is what I think's
happening this is the fall-off and the
probability of getting and one two three
four five six positive results out of
six test falling from a hundred percent
down to three percent what's actually
happening I think is that me the
scientists are actually performing
twelve studies and they're only
reporting with four or five or six that
hit statistical significance are so
unsure are consistent with our
hypothesis so because they present a
biased sample those achieving
significance we are misled as to be as
the reader in terms of what actually
happened so journals I think and quit
embark on pre-registration of studies
for instance and what's happening at
cortex links to study protocols for
instance and open science my notice some
journals are exploring bad just for this
studies could be availability this
studies got I've got a protocol
available funders could pool published
layout specs at the time of award and
could try and develop between them a a
standard format for study food laws and
be some Clearinghouse website so instead
of having to go to as many websites as
there are funders to find out where the
research had been done an organized you
could go to one place in unions and
scientists and this is our practice
should publish the protocol into the
dryer or fixture and that'll give you a
DOI and might even give you some
citations so incomplete publication is a
real problem this is the proportion of
funded and completed research that is
reported in university from nineteen
eighty to ninety six by different
jurisdictions
than ninety seven 2005 by Japan
jurisdictions and what you can see is
that overall on average 50% of research
is never published and that's the same
across countries across research areas
the only funder that the box that is
trained is the UK asta and which which
does so by withholding 10% of
grant award until the work is published
under this habit the publication bias
here's our work in animal studies and
that Emily was motivated to be published
five years ago now across through
experimental undertaking Kepler myelitis
and Alzheimer's disease models where
essentially we find that about 20% of
studies are unpublished and that leads
to an inflation in advocacy or about a
third so when you correct for the
placement or the presence of publication
bias efficacy falls by 32% and it's
interesting that the publication bias
those in different directions depending
on the research field
so here studies in environmental
toxicology each door to study and to the
writers is having an increase in pot
weight to the left is having a reduction
in pop birth weight reduction pop birth
weight is seen as being a reproductive
toxic effect or the compound under test
and what you can see in red on the
right-hand panel is 2a studies which
imputation suggests were performed but
not published and when you correct then
for publication bias I showed you an
animal disease model we observe a 40%
improvement in outcome when we correct
for publication bias we see less
improvement and that fall but in trucks
models where the outcome of interest is
potential harm we observe 0.3
standardized being different harm but
when we correct the publication bias
there's actually more hard so
publication bias doesn't always go in
the direction or doesn't always go in
the direction of understating effects it
can sometimes go in the direction of the
interest of the person doing or funding
the research and it's important to do no
harm so some of you may be aware of the
concern that there's been neonatal
anesthesia may impair cognitive
development based based largely on data
from animal experiment and when we
looked at the animal experiments we 81
publications involving three thousand
animals which we put together and
systematic review of those amazing
behavioral outcomes such as here you see
memory only 16% blinded the assessment
of memory outcome 50% randomized five
percent of the parent calculates and
only one percent blinded conduct of the
experiment we didn't meet our primary
outcome because no study made all of
those quality criteria and for instance
in the Morris water maze all overall
there seemed to be a large and
substantial effect that faith was not
present in studies at Laurel risk of
bias and some of you will have seen the
recent publication The Lancet a
randomized trial of neural development
developmental outcome at two years of
age in cohort of or in a trial of
children undergoing hernia surgery
randomized to general or recent
anesthesia with there being north egg so
little research has the potential to do
harm
not just in delaying that the
development of effective treatment but
also in encouraging parents for instance
to withhold treatment from their
children because they're concerned about
a risk of harm a risk of harm which is
ill-fated so journals need to decide
whether they're a journal of record or
whether they're one of the less
attractive journals like we used at the
sunday sport or the Daily Mail funders I
think should be fraught with all 10% of
grant pending publication I'm happy for
them to withhold 10% of my grant until I
publish work from and I think need to
think more of a new publication models
and sadducees have encouraged
rapid publications anywhere not simply
vanity public publishing in journals of
the highest impact if I've got a piece
of work which I could get public's
tomorrow in an online open access index
German people who start using it or I
could do another three experiment target
up turn up the hypo meter and then maybe
get into nature in two or three years
time
much much much better to get what I know
how to the public demean know so other
people can start validating or
invalidating or actually using the
fruits of my research and anything other
than that adds two layers to the
research process if the ethical conduct
of research is premise on the basis that
it will bring benefit to humans then to
introduce a one or two you deliver you
make things fit for publication in
nature is I think not just unwise but
also unethical
I think institutions also need to look
at appointment panels look at the work
not the packaging and and why look at
the work and not the packaging well
going back to those 2673 papers that
we've got there risks of bias or we also
had the impact factors of the journals
in which they were published and we were
able then to look to see if there was
any association between the two so we
divided the journals and by dividing the
publications by desse hours of a journal
impact factor into one is the lowest 10%
of journals by impact factor 10 is the
highest 10% moment you see a conflict of
interest statement increases an impact
factor increases because journals with
high impact factors tend to of our
policy and you have to publish a
company's of interest in sample size
calculation is lousy everywhere blinding
is pretty flat at 30 percent across the
journal impact factors and importantly
there is a statistically significant
negative association between reporting
of randomization and journal impact
factors so the higher the impact factor
the more likely the work is to be
elicited by it and so when my boss asked
me you know from one of you published
this year for our Riveter and I did
great news all of my work is published
in low impact journals which means it's
highly likely to be true and you look
slightly disappointed and shuffles
shuffles out of the room and so studies
can mislead that the sample size is
wrong here is the systematic reviewing
that we did of the efficacy of TPN on
brought in animal models of straw
publish and DAC biet then you can see
this almost 3,000 animals
but as you add animals you get so at the
top here is the first meta-analysis of
the first two studies the next one at
the first three studies the names known
as the negative fourth four studies
combined and so on and so on and here on
studies there's a learning curve and
then there's another bit of a learning
curve but after you get to about a
thousand or 1500 animals you start not
to get very much in the way of further
incremental change and we can look and
see that any final five nine was taken
to clinical trial on the basis of data
from over 500 animal so that for this it
flattened out where is the hypothermia
an intervention that we are testing in a
clinical trial in Europe for school the
animal data is submitting that we can be
filled we can be highly confident that
we've got enough information that is
adequately destroyed and what's
happening in animals because small
sample size and publication bias
conspire together so when this was an
observation from Hannah's he were that
the larger the group size he was more
than ten animal food group
the smaller the estimate of the fake so
we say time to explore why that might be
the case with some simulation studies we
assumed a complete publication bias
anything with P litter than 0.05 wasn't
published a true effect size obtained
with the big win the standard deviation
of 10 and we simulated a thousand
studies each for 5 10 15 and 20 animals
per group and if only P less than 0.05
gets published only 30 percent of these
studies here be published whereas 86% of
these studies here get published and
those of you who are weak will realize
that this is simply a bootstrapper
population but then when we take these
30% of studies that are published and
combine them in meta-analysis we find
the estimate of effect size there is 60%
higher at around 16% than the true
effect size which were trying to model
and even in studies which which we would
consider to be adequately powered there
is still an overstatement bar non
significant August even of effect in the
overall estimate and so that's a problem
of small sample sizes how does that
happen well
imaginary sets of studies on the left
here altitude totality - and the lab to
your studies done with lost a testicle
para or the right here studies done with
high statistical power each of them and
testing and a thick which comes in at
about twenty five percent so if we take
the average in each of these then and we
get an overall estimate of efficacy of
twenty five percent but that's not what
happens because in the under Paris
studies that studies missing and so when
we do this summary that's your more
estimate that we get and there's a
longer statement in efficacy then this
is a 10 percent is because the
suppression the non publication of non
significant neutral underpowered studies
so underpowered studies mislead
statistical power is a function both of
the number the difference between groups
availability and statistical threshold
you choose an efforts to increase power
or reduce the aliens may also reduce
generalizability now it's an important
caution because the more we try and nail
down our experiment so we could play a
long variant the more it will be easier
to see what happens in our experiment
with greater precision but the less
those findings rule and being able to be
generalized to twelve the situation so
other animals twelve circumstances to
other levels and this is my attempt to
create the number as a Johnny losses
paper point most published research as
false in any study you've got the
statistical power and you've got the
hypothesis testing so if we take an arm
for a hypothesis over everything an
alpha and threshold at no point naught 5
that implies of those studies which are
truly negative ninety five percent will
be called negative and five percent will
be called positive and we've got a power
and I've taken power here at forty
percent then if our biological effect is
truly there then forty percent the
studies will find it and sixty percent
of the studies
but what people miss when they think
about those significance testing is that
it is critical to know what the
proportion of potential studies are that
are absolutely positive or to be
negative because what you're interested
in isn't the result of your your Pietist
which is if this was negative only 5% of
studies would find this answer what
you're interested in is if I've got a
positive result how likely it is that
that positive result is a food processor
so here we're assuming that 20% of
hypotheses are correct we're assuming
the power of 40% and we take a p-value
of less than 0.05 as a threshold so all
flawless 20% of studies will be positive
all of those 20% of studies that are
posted 40% 40% of 20% is 8 percent 8
percent will test positive 12% will test
negative
oh the 80% of studies which are truly
negative 95 percent which is 76 percent
will test negative but 4 percent will
test positive so overall we all get 12
percent of studies will test positive on
which 8 percent will be truly positive
and 4 percent will be truly will be
truly negative so the positive
predictive value about there is 67
percent normal 95 percent and that's not
well understood let's go hunting if 1
percent of hypotheses are correct name
with peridot 40 percent of P and P less
than 0.05 the positive predictive value
if you work it out is 7 percent even if
you take your lesson number one no fun
so how do you get to something closer to
what you expect well the 20% of
hypotheses are correct I don't think
that's an unreasonable starting point if
Paris at 80 percent and you take a P of
less a naught point naught 1 then you
get a possible value of not 95% so I
would argue that we need to change the
way that we think about doing our
experiment that instead of taking power
around about your 50% and a p-value have
no point note 5 we should take power at
80% and a p-value have no point
one so if you look at the combination of
Peace facials and statistical power
required to give that positive
predictive value of 95% where the
prevalence and truly positive studies is
one in five then you can see that this
line and when you've got absolutely
statistical power your piece facial is
about no point no 1/3 and if you're
powered at 40% then the p-value that you
would have to take facial will be no
point no not five and that point at 80%
at people and P facial have no point not
one is I think a happy medium of the
achievable versus the desirable so
improvement strategies funders require
real power calculations and to provide
expertise and experimental design and
some of you may know that the you KN see
two yards have recently launched the
experimental design a system which which
I would recommend to you and I think
regulators should end the tyranny of
reduction you there are many reasons why
experiments are too small but one of
them is that so people can write in
their ethics application we have reduced
the number of animals to the minimum
required and that also happens to
minimize the time I need to spend in the
experiment and I have also minimizes the
cost associated with experiment and
normally and calls out a study for being
underpowered and we should call out
studies for the underpowered institution
we should provide in-house expertise in
statistical design and the scientists we
should cut our forth according to our
code and what I mean by there is that if
we don't have enough experimental
subjects to answer the question that we
want to pause with sufficient
statistical power we should ask a
different question because there's no
merit in doing underpowered experiment
no merit whatsoever and there are other
cautions harking I told them a bit about
earlier on hypothesizing afterwards also
knowing where you click the data you run
a number of different and outcome
measures and then you try and put
together a hypothesis that fits the one
that made a piece a sort of no point not
fine
and flexibility in data analysis where
you perhaps have an experiment where
it's possible to measure the outcome in
different ways so in our Alzheimer's
work at the Morris water maze in 50t
publications to you in 59 different
statistical analysis approaches to
measuring the outcome in the Morris
water maze and you can imagine that
people don't use all of these different
outcomes just because they've got a
personal favorite but rather they'll
report the ways of measuring the outcome
that happened to fit their hypothesis I
need to get around a lot of these
problems I think by the introduction of
protocols population define hypothesis
intervention a sample size calculation
primary outcome measure and statistical
analysis plan and you can say that I
just on one side of a4 with ten words
under each not let our weight on your
institutional website and when you
submit your paper for publication give
the link to the reviewers and when you
publish your people give the link to
your readers so they know that you
actually did what you set out to do a
good test of the hypothesis of course
will give you a clear answer the
hypothesis will either be confirmed in
green or refuted but the problem is that
many of our hypotheses allow us because
of willingness in the way Linda
characterized to be fairly flexible I
suppose is a word in the way in which
the results were interpreted or the
memorable Karl Karl Popper said some
genuinely testable theories when claimed
to be false are still upheld by their
admirers for an example by introducing
ad hoc some exhilaration or by
reinterpreting the theory I hope in such
a winner to discuss reputation such a
procedure is always possible that a
rescues the theory from the application
only in the place of destroying or at
least lowering their scientific status
and it's much better to to spend more
time getting a hypothesis right and are
being a difficult test under your
hypothesis rather than having something
quite bully which you know is going to
give you a bit of wiggle room if you
don't get the answer that you like and
we're certain things go wrong and people
use the wrong model
so here's hypertension and Stroke n8y on
five nine I talked about this briefly
earlier on the overall estimate of
etiquette
the vertical gray bar but in
hypertensive animals here much reduced
efficacy 7% of animal studies when
animal from hypertension 77 percent of
patients in the neutral sin since to
study had hypertension
here's clot-busting treatment here's the
treatment that works
TPA nine percent of animal studies we
use a new animal market engine doesn't
do anything in animals and hypertension
but fortunately I think it probably was
Fortin the pivotal name study of TPA in
school specifically excluded patients
with a history of hypertension so the
TPA research was done in humans which
were most like the animals in which
efficacy had been shown and here you can
see some validation of an old model
system again TPA and clot busting
treatment for stroke this is a decline
in efficacy in ninety minute epochs from
the time of occlusion in animal studies
in the land and the clinical studies on
the right each involve about 3,000
subjects so they're fairly low cost
estimates those error bars are the 95
percent confidence intervals lalamon
standard deviations or standard errors
and you can see that those lines while
they don't descend completely exactly on
top of one another
tell us the same general story that over
the first four to six hours after stroke
there's a decline in efficacy to not
very much efficacy being Laird so
scientists I think need to develop
better validation of their animal models
and perhaps done to targeted experiments
I nailed yeah I started this for motor
neuron disease for ALS and with
remarkable results a systematic reviews
of hundred experiments as we have done
and comparing models and different
outcome measures to understand well of
the animal model does have any laws
abilities within it employs abilities
and the data that I soon that mean that
it is of limited or reduced value I
think also want to be good are validated
animal studies we need to think about
different ways of doing those pivotal
proof-of-concept preclinical trials
perform going into human clinical trial
and we've advocated and done the
properity work to a large multicenter
animal studies to be done in the same
way that we do
Center human clinical trials so we can
improve the chance of translational
success if we systematically review the
available data conduct further in vivo
experiments if indicated design our
clinical trials according to what the
animal data actually say not what we
would like them to see and develop tools
and we're involved with a number of
groups doing this to allow rapid living
systematic reviews of animal data so the
clinical trial decisions can be informed
by the very latest information from the
lab or even not information is perhaps
one or two years old and if you look at
the people that I've been criticizing
for the last 50 minutes
they're the funders and the journals and
the regulators and institutions but at
the heart of each of these are the peers
because the peers who review for the
funder who review from the journals who
sit on regulatory panels who run our
institutions so this isn't a problem
that's out there that we need to get
other people to think for us it's a
problem that we can start to fix every
day in our working life and we should
all take the pledge and start to do so
science is not as currently conceived a
profession we don't have a court of
professional ethics we don't have a
regulatory body we don't have continuing
professional development even a
professional football player soccer
players for those of you in the States
have a accorded professional ethics they
have to do 16 hours a year very
presumably even a new look line they're
told that they're not supposed to bite
their opponents on the shoulder and if
they don't do the CPD and they're not
allowed to play in scientists don't have
that I'm issued and we should have
accorded professional ethics and we
could have we should have and robust and
systematized tools for continuing
professional development perhaps
enforced or reinforced are supported by
biannual programs of appraisal and done
not for accountability and how many
grants have you got how many papers have
you published but appraisal by appear
outside the immediate research team to
try and explore with the scientists what
they might be able to develop in terms
of their scientific toolkit to improve
the research which they do in the future
so my key message is stay in vivo
studies but you know on the points
implement
to avoid bias give larger estimates of
treatment of AIDS and unfortunately
Muslim people studies do not report
simple measures to reduce bias
publication and selective outcome
reporting biases are important and
prevalent one cannot assume rigor even
in journals where one would think that
you could have sealed it there we've
only been able to find this stuff out by
studying large numbers of studies now
that encourage you either to do that
yourself or to support others who do and
crucially any experimental design can be
subverted what's important is learning
how to recognize when when that's
happened so how big a hole does this
make and publish research as relates to
animals well that this is the totality
or published research you lose about 20%
because of risk of bias 20% the bone I
was arguing you you lose about 20% from
publication bias from the 20% of studies
that aren't published kind of clearly
lost and I think you lose about the
number 20% from under parrot experiment
so overall one could argue that 60% of
animal research is not as efficient
there's not a useful as of 9 otherwise
be because of these three very simple
reasons that we could all do something
about thinking about tomorrow I'd like
to thank my collaborators particularly
Emily but the horn extended commander
Steve thundered if you'd be interested
in doing a set amount of you we are here
to help you could send an email I'd be
delighted to reply and how they know we
can have a question and answer session
but thank you for your attention
Thank You Malcolm now it's interesting
after all these years I still learn
anything good and sometimes I'm about to
get started with our question and answer
session I'd like to remind the audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window window we'll try
to answer as many questions as we can
our first question it's from sherry
Gross from UC Davis
she asks will you please clarify the
need for replica study if perón are
these have been used to determine the
number of animals needed but
specifically that it results in
having reproducible bodies that can be
achieved by another lab at another
institution yeah great question so so
and there's if you wanted to be busy and
you start off with a prior and you do
your study and then you apply your base
back and then you get a posterior
probability that what you're seeing is
true so what are the reasons for
replication would be if you're a prior
probability is so long and your your
probability is so low that even with an
adequately powered experiment you're
still getting a pursuit of probability
only up to 50 or 60 percent you might
want yourself to do another study to get
that pastino probability up to nineteen
ninety-five percent certainly into
clinical trials and the FDA would
require to opportunity three clinical
trials for a stroke run because such is
the graveyard of through drugs that even
with that I try a post about five
percent that the senior probability that
that drug actually works is only right
about 38 percent so and so that's the
first reason but actually I think
there's a much more important reason and
and that's about the generalizability of
findings so there was some great work
that was done long time ago published in
science by going in crab I think where
they looked at the replication of
behavioral findings and in eight
different groups of animals for eight
different outcome measures across three
different labs in Portland Albany and I
think Carly but only I've got that wrong
and and for instance in medicine anxiety
they had a 5ht knockout animal and that
animal compared with its wild time in
one lab and the null kind seemed to
increase anxiety in another lab is
significantly reduced anxiety in a third
lab that had nor fate and uragan so you
were getting absolutely tangibly
different results and using the same
animals using the same protocols just by
different than just by different tests
and so and and so there's a there's an
issue of our generalizability Hanna
wearable and colleagues have done
something
interesting work about her and you can
think particularly in the question that
in the issue of developing a drug for a
stroke while you're trying to breach
that species barrier if you've already
been able to beat a species barrier from
iris to rat to rather to cat for
instance then one might assume that and
the probability of being able to reach
that species barrier to humans would
also be higher so the more homogenous
the circumstances of testing the more
precise the estimate but the lesson
realizable the more heterogeneous the
circumstance of testing the more animals
you need but I think the more robust the
finding and so we are starting to try
and articulate a model whereby early
experimental discovery work is done in
highly homogenized single site
experiments to try and work out exactly
and whether there's a signal there but
the four take into clinical trial one
embarks on the polar opposite type of
experiment with lots and lots of
heterogeneity and lots and lots of
different centers on the basis that I
drug the fluids efficacy across that
wide range of circumstances is much more
likely to generalize to human clinical
trial and that's one of the main drivers
are principles behind the multi center
of course multi parts approach to
preclinical and multicenter clinical
trials for animals because we think it
will give us much more robust hands okay
thank you we'll just give it a couple
and more seconds if you get any more my
students
okay and I think we don't have any more
questions at once again I'd like to
thank Malcolm those presentations have
any final comments that you want to know
just time thank you all 250 of you and
for a million 249 first early huh and I
hope the rest of beauty is interesting
and successful thank you so today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing six months from today I believe
you will receive an email from labret
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we write to fall
with that announcement to your
colleagues who may have its own live
event thank you again for attending and
goodbye